[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
alors
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui t'arrive
ce qui parle et je suis je vais aller au
ski ah bon et je descendais une piste
noire et mais mes jambes n'ont pas pris
la même décision a donc dû coucher très
très mal et je vais voter marine le pen
je veux que les pistes noires retournent
dans leur pays voilà ce que je veux
non seulement ça commençait mal peur
celle qui a drucker je connais de ce nom
mais je serais incapable chef de choeur
voilà déjà
michel drucker ne se
méfie bride a peur après les couches pas
les couches
et voilà le de ambulatoire de michel
attends pas non non la figure d'un
signalement va s'inverser beaucoup posé
là derrière l'as si bien le le
déambulateur est ce que je peux l'avoir
devant pascal s'il veut faire un petit
tour du plateau michel mademoiselle
mademoiselle s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
ça vient
si vous restez derrière michel on sait
jamais ça peut arriver michel drucker et
quand même quelqu'un m'attende à csg
tarifs j'arrive n'arrive à shariff they
were messieurs vainqueur
[Applaudissements]
chaque crise est 6ème
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
michel
ça c'est après l'émission là bas tout le
monde dit qu'il est dur car il arrive
aux genoux
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les corrections de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu